Transcriptor: Ainhoa Muñoz
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
¿Cuál de estas dos personas...
es más confiable?
¿Cuál de estas dos personas
es más espiritual?
Una de estas dos personas
robó en el supermercado.
¿Quién fue?
Un estudio de la Universidad
de Goldchamps,
realizado a más de 45 000 personas,
demostró que tardamos menos de un segundo
en aceptar o rechazar a una persona
en nuestro primer encuentro.
En menos de un segundo, nuestra mente
ya sabe si esa persona nos cae bien o no.
Si queremos que se acerque, o se aleje,
que hable o que calle.
La decisión: "¿Te quiero? ¿No te quiero?
¿Confío en ti? ¿No confío en ti?
¿Me atraes? ¿No me atraes?"
está fundamentada por una enorme
cantidad de argumentos
que hemos ido acumulando
a lo largo de toda nuestra vida.
Vivencias, relatos, conversaciones,
mitos, leyendas, verdades y mentiras.
Estos días aquí en la Argentina,
oí una frase que me gustó mucho
y quisiera hoy compartir con Uds.
Oí que alguien decía:
"El que se quema con leche
ve una vaca y llora".
(Risas)
Y yo pensaba: "¿Por qué?"
La vaquita inocente comiendo el pasto,
(Risas)
y nosotros a su lado llorando.
Es que el modo en el que cada uno
de nosotros interpreta la realidad,
está condicionado por nuestra
predisposición mental.
Que a su vez, está condicionada
por todas las experiencias del pasado.
Hace un tiempo, en el
Himalaya, un monje me dijo:
"John, ¿tú has ido alguna
vez a las islas de Hawái?"
"No", le dije yo.
"¿Pero para ti existen?"
"Sí, claro".
"¿Y cómo sabes que existen
si nunca las has visto?"
"Bueno, pues porque las he visto en
vídeos, documentales y demás imágenes".
"De eso quería hablar", me dijo el monje.
Gran parte de lo que creemos conocer
no lo hemos conocido en primera persona,
nos lo han contado.
Entendemos el mundo a partir de imágenes,
relatos,
notas de prensa, películas,
y sobre todo, los medios
masivos de comunicación.
Entonces, si nuestro modo
de entender el mundo
y de habitarlo, depende de
nuestras fuentes de información,
más vale que sean confiables.
Sin embargo, les traigo malas noticias.
Un estudio de la
Universidad de Morthens,
sostiene que tres de cada
cuatro artículos en la prensa
contienen serias inconsistencias.
Otro artículo afirma que
7 de cada 10 periodistas,
en lugar de investigar,
prefieren ver Netflix.
(Risas)
Hay otro estudio que sostiene
que un estudio afirma que los estudios
podrían no ser del todo confiables.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Y finalmente, hay un estudio
de la Universidad de Wonderful,
que sostiene
que ningún dato de los que
fueron ofrecidos en esta charla,
(Risas)
son ciertos.
Que quien les habla
no tiene 80 años, sino 33,
(Risas)
que no nació en Estados Unidos
de Norteamérica
sino en Argentina.
(Risas)
Que no es un académico,
sino un actor.
Y el estudio concluye diciendo,
que vivimos demasiado
convencidos y convencidas,
de que nuestro modo de ver el mundo
es la posta.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)